oh wait who's in it a lot of people hey
guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Randy fresh we're gonna check out
the official teaser trailer for The
Jungle Book starring a [ __ ] ton of
people directed by Jon Favreau the
director of Cowboys & Aliens and Zathura
here we go
an elf let's not forget elf and chef
chef swingers swingers yeah there's one
more missing Disney definitely can
monetize this video are you alone out
here what are you doing so deep in the
jungle
don't you know what you are
I know
I know where you came
for sweet little cow
I'll keep you close
let go of your fear now
tres no I knew it
they're super walking
huh IMAX huh I'll be there for that yeah
that looks visually stimulating it does
it really looks cool it kind of has a
life of P vibe PI P EE what's there you
stupid what is that that's life of Peeta
angley movie oh yeah that's right it's
like we hear facts yeah right it kind of
has that kind of vibe about it maybe
because there's like a tiger and [ __ ]
involved I don't know a lot of green
screen probably yeah I'm wonder if it's
gonna be a jogger
so you're Tiger of Russia I was
definitely being efficient yeah if I
gotta got me that was like her oh [ __ ]
it looks like an awesome world of this
jungle you know at the snake snakes
freaked me out I don't I don't do well
around snakes at all like I have a
friend as a pet snake and it's like hey
you must think I'm like [ __ ] you I'll
murder you if you bring that snake out
here oh [ __ ] your mom murder your dad
and then I'll burn your whole ass that
gets out of control that that's fair
yeah he's a kid's movie so I figured you
know show them what adults really think
like the effects look great I want to
hear more of the voices of the other
characters I'm smart marketing to have
the snake be the one who's talking the
whole trailer oh yeah Scarlett Johansson
has a beautiful voice she does and you
know like she carried her with just her
voice
I like that casting choice I don't
remember the isn't it's based off a book
right Jungle Book yeah yeah actually
makes sense
yeah I never read the book I've seen the
cartoon I've seen the dragon the Bruce
Lee story star Jason Scott Lee he
starred in The Jungle Book remember that
real-life annotation yeah that wasn't
very good it was okay that wasn't very
good this looks like they're actually
able because it's like they had all the
animals and [ __ ] but knew they weren't
talking or anything
Danis it takes away strong element
without the talking animals I like how
also there the lips are not moving in
the animals I don't know why I get a
annoyed at that because it's like he has
a so sort of telepathy with them they
can be distracting because it looks so
CGI when it happens yeah exactly
if you read the not like the novel and
Rudyard Kipling he wrote it and it's
just like la there's a lot of darker
themes in it which I think this one is
addressing this looks like an epic film
you know like when it's it from the
studio that brought you pirates the
Caribbean and then the trailer
progressed I was like this really does
feel like the studio that brought you
Pirates of the Caribbean this looks
[ __ ] epic right and I just wonder who
all the characters are because you have
Bill Murray Ben Kingsley Idris Elba
Lupita Nyong'o who's Lupita Nyong'o um
did you see 12 years of slave yes she
played the female slave the one that
Michael Fassbender raped yeah that one
she do that's all she'll forever be
known as she studied as at Juilliard
yeah I want to see who Bill Murray's
playing cuz Bill Murray's like the last
person to agree to do anything so now
I'm kind of interest I'm interested to
see this is a big studio film and he's
like agreeing to be a part of it yeah
he's either gonna be Balu which is the
bear mm-hmm or whose the sarcastic kind
of orangutan oh I forgot is me yeah I
forgot I haven't seen that I haven't
seen how long it's been forever since
I've taken any look at any jungle book
related yeah but an interest Elba I
think would be really cool in yeah yeah
he's probably who's Baloo again the bear
the bear
Essene if he has a very deep voice I see
mr. panther cuz the Panthers black so be
more there's there's something about
when you come on this channel that makes
you well I make I make a black joke and
it doesn't fly over well with anyone
including me yeah everyone's like you're
racist Ryan and then all the black subs
are like I thought it was funny once you
Christopher Walken plays I know it's
like you before to think I'm the bear I
can't do it mice the hell
to a bucket of cream I don't have a good
walk
Chango whoa it's not matter though it's
really good at really yeah my great
affinity for it
I like Mowgli your little boy oh maybe
it's just a teaser trailer so we can't
really go too much in depth with the
review but what they're trying to convey
tone feels epic visuals look [ __ ]
great I wonder who the little boy is I
don't know it's funny how they list like
a castle like a people with a don't
bother to say and introducing the main
character yeah Mowgli I want it I want
to know that kid is it kind of also has
a little bit remember um the animated
version of Tarzan the Disney one yeah
yeah it kind of has a little bit of that
vibe thrown in there two ways like
hopping around the trees and [ __ ] yeah
it's Disney you know so Disney knows how
to bring live action adventure too you
know it's like I'm not upset at how
they're doing all these adaptations of
their classic cartoons and it doesn't
bother me because a lot of them are
pretty good you know like the Cinderella
one was not bad this one looks pretty
[ __ ] awesome I like Cinderella yeah a
lot of people did got like really good
reviews too and Jon Favreau man he knows
how to make an entertaining film really
does he really knows how to make an
entertaining film and while still
staying true to the story yeah exactly
Iron Man everyone knows was great I
personally enjoyed most of cowboys and
Aliens I know I didn't get the greatest
feedback but I enjoyed it for the most
part I want to check this movie out
already I want to see a theatrical
trailer where I'm sure it's Jon Favreau
so and it's a Disney movie so they're
making this like first epic teaser but
I'm sure there's gonna be plenty of
humor in this film that they're just not
conveying in this trailer but I want to
see another trailer where we do get a
touch of that humor well you kind of get
an idea of it just by the end when he
starts singing fairness fairness esse
T's yeah that's simple badass uh this
looks like the jungle book live
adaptation that we deserve yes we got it
people we've been asking for decades now
we got it anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real read
you can check out brandy prices channel
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter me on vine and
periscope and let's do a shout out you
know I want to shout out actually
Savannah
[ __ ] wild she just turned 17 recently
meaning you're almost legal in the
United States and you are one of the
most dedicated subscribers comments all
the time
tweets all the time so happy birthday to
you Savannah happy birthday I believe
you're British and black black bridge so
raw oh my all rot me a black brick raw
happy but do you survive I don't know
what I'm doing these are horrible the
British accent just went away
I don't know he was this more like my
stolen vomiting yeah it was like a
Stallone happy birthday happy birthday